very happy that I managed to assemble a
nice team of panelists
to be honest this is a this is a bit
embarrassing but we kind of schedule the
panel and then I woke up this morning
and I realize oh my god there's this
panel what what are we going to do so I
was fairly lucky that I managed to
convince these seem gentleman over there
to participate in our panel they're all
going to introduce themselves in a
second and there's Peter Coyle who's
going to be hosting it and then we have
five chairs for five participants and
the topic of the panel discussion is the
state of data science and Python in
Berlin / germany / europe and i'll be in
the audience with this microphone here
so feel free to ask questions for the
panelists we're trying to create sort of
an interactive discussion as well anyway
please let's get started so thanks
everyone for joining us for this and I'm
gonna first start by letting everybody
introduce themselves and sort of tell
what area of the data science spectrum
they're in and they're asked a couple of
questions and I get a bit of a show of
hands from the audience because I'm very
interested not actually living in Berlin
I live in Luxembourg despite being Irish
and what industries you're in because I
imagine there's a different set of
people here than you would get in PI D
to London or in pike on Ireland or any
of the other events so could we start
with Felix yeah so hi I'm Felix I'm
actually coming from particle physics so
working there as let's say data analyst
in the bigger experiment at cern and
family and from that corner i'm now
working also i'm more like on the
scientific corner of the machine
learning stuff and I'm in Brianna now so
this is a company which is delivering
software as a service predictive
application solutions for customers from
I don't know all kind of industrial
sectors and there i'm mostly working in
the development of our core libraries so
that means
actually building stuff for the
customers which they need but for that
we have to to have our own methods and
extend all the stuff which is there an
pies in which we are using exhaustively
and for that we are developing a lot of
things a lot of cool stuff and this is
where I mean good right Heather I guess
you saw me talk this morning but my
background is I'm trained as an
electrical engineer and a computer
scientist and I've been doing artificial
intelligence related things for about 20
years doing radio classification and
doing a lot of stuff for the
semiconductor industry and with my most
recent company in the world of web scale
internet machine learning that sort of
thing and a whole variety of different
tools have used under this umbrella of
artificial intelligence some that would
be considered machine learning these
days you know back in the days we called
it there's all these different things
right fuzzy logic and evolutionary
computation and a whole bunch of
different subfields at overlap and I
pretty much done the ball over the years
and at scale to you know up to a
trillion points you know ten dimensions
million dimensions all these sorts of
things so covered a lot of ground and my
role has always been CTO of the
different companies have been involved
with i also have a PhD in the
relationship between computers and
creativity as applied to computer chip
design so that's my background and it's
really a pleasure to be here Thanks hi
I'm Daniel Rios I learned to program
three years ago but my background has
been in a lot of problem solving I have
a bachelor's degree in literature and if
you can imagine that and I work for
paper in T which is a tea company I do a
little bit of programming there but i'll
be speaking in my capacity as in my free
time I'm one of the co-chairs of the
Python colanders group in Berlin which
is held under the open texaco Berlin
umbrella every Monday every other monday
sorry hi I'm Cheney janaka found a CEO
of chakra chakra is our index that helps
venture capitalists understand or make
decisions around private companies in
Europe
really similar to made a mock in the US
I mean Silicon Valley um and in New York
CB insights my background actually is in
health care so I spend quite a lot of
time in health care I I guess worked
with in quite some large companies one
Humana in New York and Aetna in London
so the both of large health insurance
organizations and those role within the
MA shop my role was actually helped like
sort of you know detect trends find look
for ways in which we can kind of your
build algorithms to make decisions on
some of the deals that we were making so
today I'm going to be talking a little
bit about venture capital arm the index
that we're building by building that on
Python arm and some of the insights that
we've already gathered from that hey i'm
nico i work at ike one which you can see
just between us where I'm responsible
for product development and tech if
you're not familiar with what we're
doing we do we call it i'm going to call
it today human perception prediction
which essentially where we do two things
at the moment one is we can take images
of websites display ads and email
designs and tell you where people are
most likely to look based on a whole
bunch of neuroscience research that's
kind of ended up in eye tracking data
which we've used to train some models
and we're also we also have in
development and live a number of scores
where you can sort of get a score on how
likely it is that certain people judge
your designs in a certain way so the one
we've got right now is one which can
tell you how cluttered your website is
for example which as you can imagine if
you're trying to do some marketing and
have a message to show is what people
are interested in and my background I
thought I was going to say I'm the odd
one out here because I don't consider
myself a data scientist but seems like
I'm not the only odd one out I do have a
background in computational linguistics
so of course there was some machine
learning and number crunching involved
but i think these days i probably
couldn't matrix multiply my way
out of a paper bag but i hope i have
some perspective because we of course
use a lot of the you know an umpire's i
could learn etc tools in all I modeling
it's a bit like past partial isn't it
and so that's a very interesting mixture
and so let's just have a show of hands
from the audience who here
self-identifies as a data scientist so
and we're at a data scientist conference
and not everyone's hand went up that's
very interesting and so what about like
an industry split right so my my prior
might be as IAM prior would be there
everybody be an e-commerce but i'm
probably wrong with that so so what kind
of like let's start with industry and
research right so who's in research so
by fifty percent of the audience and
who's in industry so it's by a 50-50
split and or maybe i miscounted that um
and so if we look at the research and
what about biology they're sort of the
life sciences firstly life sciences and
secondly the hard sciences so physics
sorry that that's a bit controversial
say it's good way to excite the audience
just offend them um so am and what about
in the industry split am so who's in the
e-commerce sector so not everyone I'm
water by marketing I'll have to go with
other actually and for the rest of them
sorry okay so so that's an interesting
mixture we have here so we're going to
start with the first question which is
what you does a panel think of the data
science seen in peril
and then we can extend it to Europe so
i'll start with feelings so for the
Berlin stuff I think we should start
with Niko right well it's a great
question i think you know when you've
got your head down and building stuff it
can sometimes be really easy not to
engage in scene at all so I like I'm
really amazed by the turnout we've had
here like I've been to one or two
potatoes before like the meetups I've
been to one of the machine learning
meetup groups that are around here and I
just yeah I'm just blown away by how
much turnout there's been here and the
quality of the talks so I think there's
probably a lot more to it than meets the
eye and but sort of for my personal
perception I think Matt in his first
keynote yesterday had this this nice
like segmentation of data you know
you've got the the gigabyte data the
terrible idea the padded by data and for
what we're doing we're often dealing
with relatively small data sets you know
we've got maybe thousands of you know
website PNG's or ten tens of thousands
of those they never exceed the gigabyte
scale and like a lot of the most
interesting stuff is obviously in the
terabyte scale because that's where
everything breaks but I'm like I would
like to see more of the sort of like
small data data science stuff and maybe
there's a lot of it out there that I'm
not aware of but yeah that's sure um
yeah I guess my take on the data science
um I guess row of field here in Berlin
it's still kind of developing at least
from what I'm seen if I compare it to
some of the other places for example
London there's definitely room for
improvement I think that at least what
I'm seen here with data science is that
a lot of it is limited to e-commerce um
and that it's still the definition as
well is something that
it is still growing so there's
definitely a lot of debate around what
is a data scientist um what are the
skills that you need um are we talking
about you have in I don't know like
business intelligence skills and you
using SAS are we talking about you being
a mere machine using machine learning
techniques so that's definitely a lot of
that there but yeah I guess I'll say
that is developing and at least from
what I'm seeing in Berlin versus in
London um yeah there's there's
definitely it's growing so what when I
started going to the Python co-learning
group one of my focuses was you know web
technologies and I was really glad to
find a lot of other people doing flask
doing Django but as time went on I
started notice people there I was like
oh whoa you know what do you do and they
go oh I'm a biologist and I'm doing and
then they would say something I had no
idea about but they were using Python
this way that I never imagined that it
could be used because I never paid
attention to the scientific aspect of it
there's also we get a lot of people a
lot of beginners who are in physics and
biology and they sort of want to take
control of their own data and analyze
their own data and we get I mean they
don't sometimes they come two times
three times but there is a lot of
interest I feel especially amongst them
people in the sciences is not
necessarily that big companies but just
people doing it for their own research
or their own labs so
one of the three core organizers of
machine learning berlin meetup group and
there's about 900 members in it and we
have monthly meetings and every single
time it fills up we our biggest
challenge actually is getting venues
that are big enough each time so
sometimes we have a venue with 40 people
sometimes 60 sometimes 150 in fact we've
had several meetups in this room with
150 people and there's always a waiting
list so to me that's very promising and
the people who give the talks it's
actually a really high caliber of talks
that we have it's we're always very
impressed by the ones that come through
besides that the other groups that are
sort of more prominent in the machine
the Berlin scene there's the algorithms
and data challenges group run by Alex
Wyse and come it's about every two
months it's got really excellent
speakers etc there's the big data beers
group run by a couple also Python
experts and it's also like really great
and there's machine learning a group for
learning run by a Marcel Ackerman of
Amazon and they meet up every I think
two weeks also to learn and improve they
review papers all of this besides those
groups which are very active there are
several other meetups that are you know
a little less often but also quite
popular too so from the perspective of
you know the meetups that are happening
there's quite a lot going on actually
and to me it's been quite exciting to
see and all these groups sort of emerged
in the last sort of year and a half two
and a half years some of them even in
the last six months so from my
perspective that's quite exciting you
know within companies and so on I have
some visibility I probably don't have
the best but at least from a media
perspective I see a lot and I see a lot
of not only quantity but quality yes I
from you also i think the conference
talks are really great so what I liked
most is that we are not too much um
still in the scientific corner of the
thing but there are a lot of companies
now also here we are doing technical
talks so on to what Nico set so I think
this is so we are mostly and for the
machine learning stuff we aren't small
data sets still that's true but actually
in industry and Internet of Things and
all this stuff so we are really facing
that the bigger data sets now so i think
the ideas which were
talked about on this conference are this
what we are actually facing at the
moment as well so that we see that we
need some out-of-court solutions that we
need some algorithms which can be
streamed and so on so I think this is
very interesting that to see that this
is also coming a bit to this to this
community here and yeah so that's very
interesting because I come from a
physics background as well so like and I
haven't had the proper computational
training as mazing hi constantly running
the challenges I have to pick up what
I'd of core is I probably didn't know
what a RESTful API was three years ago
so and so I guess this here kind of is
there any questions from the audience or
do you want me to go to go on with the
next question so so there's something I
just oh sorry so blah hi I'm also a
physicist and actually ever remark to
you a question and also what I've heard
here you asked for iOS other sitting
here people who are doing e-commerce and
marketing and then it is said well it's
not not a lot about other things in
Berlin but you actually has no assets so
my background is physicist and many
physicists learned matlab and then went
over to my senior so engineering is of
course also an important thing to ask so
so i guess the follow up there is sort
of how people comment on what other
industries there are I know I'm sorry
for leaving like physics and I'm the
kind of industrial engineering know like
if I have a finite set i'm going to
leave someone right right
yeah yeah so there's kind of a branding
problem they're right you know so like
you talk about Python a lot of people
think your web apps you know so I've
been at like a few pop icon and
everything was quite web app dominated
where's there's a different skill source
set of skills so I'd like to ask people
to comment a bit on what they think
their industries are in in in Berlin and
in Europe you are using data science
yeah so compared to the US and UK maybe
so we have not too much coming from
finance insurance and center and that
saying so mostly i would say in germany
and then also in europe mostly it's what
we had for example is mostly retail in
the past so just because they're the
pressure was the highest that they need
some sophisticated methods to earn some
money and in industry for example this
wasn't the case in the past so there's
there was so much money in that it was
not necessary to have the last per cents
out of your data so but this changed now
with all this Internet of Things stuff
and I think this is now catching up so
there will be a lot of things to come
and industry and all these things and I
think this will be a pretty interesting
in the future so I have the question is
what industries are using data science
and to me it actually comes down to what
is the definition of data science I have
to admit I'm really not a big fan of the
label data science I never have been I
think that there's it it has the word
science did a lot of the time what
you're doing is engineering whereas in
science what you need to do is you know
you have you have questions that you
want to answer you post these testable
hypotheses you come up with an approach
to do it you gather data than you do an
analysis but a lot of the time people
who claim to be data scientists are
doing data science or just wrangling
data right so in my view rather than the
label data and then if you're I've also
seen kind of related to this the problem
of the label you know a company hires a
data scientist or a team of data
scientist something like go play with
theta there's no actionable outcome and
IV I've been even seen
and companies I've been involved with
where we would hire algorithm teams
before there were data science is sexy
and these teams failed actually and we
actually just I have two different cases
where we hired these teams we disbanded
those teams and we put them part of
engineering and product development and
then we had technical spikes and from
those technical spikes you know where
you go away for two weeks or two months
you have an actionable outcome at the
end so in terms of in terms of that
that's kind of my view is what are the
different skill sets that kind of relate
to data science there's database
engineering which is simply you know
data keeps growing and now people call
it big cool but the databases have been
around a long time machine learning
right there's been simple analytics for
decades statistics all of this right now
the modern statistics happens to be
called machine learning cool and there's
a lot of great new tools so I mean and
these happen to have broader
applications so my kind of view is the
bulk of what is called data science is
really machine learning and and
databases but these are engineering
rules and product development roles and
that's where I like to see them what
industries to me like I mean databases
are everywhere right it statistics is
everywhere and so data science in a
sense is everywhere Oh Trent you stole
my answer one of the things that I've
noticed in some of the companies that
I've worked for and the people that I've
talked to is that there's a lot of data
being pulled there's a lot of data being
collected but not very many decisions
being made with the data is just sort of
like oh we have you know big data we
have all these servers running in
numbers crunching but in the end there
needs to be an outcome there needs to be
someone who makes the decision says okay
we're going to put eighty-five percent
more money in the marketing budget or
we're gonna you know increase the
physics department spending and I sort
of feel that in a way we have all these
tools we're doing all these things but
we need to almost push a little bit
further and say okay what was the
outcome of my return statement you know
what happened to it and I think
sometimes a lot of my data that I
generate you know I don't do the follow
up partly because you know i'm not the
decision-maker I'm just sort of
delivering the data and it almost feels
like when you deliver it at
that's unused you sort of feel like you
know what was the point except that you
learned something awesome you know so
I'm going to comment on two industries
so the first one being health care in a
second one beam venture capital on terms
of health care choices my us experiences
an example so in health care some of the
things that we were looking at with data
was hard for insurance is how do we
manage costs using large sets of data
that we already have on consumers so in
this case when I worked for human are
for example we're managing a little over
five million members so we had a lot of
claims data on this customers so
everything around you know how do we how
do we decide or how do we prevent pain
as initially um and how do we estimate
what we pay for you know for condition
condition areas so you give you example
of some of the data with some of the
things that we did second example of
health care application around big data
epidemiology so a lot of people talk
here about data science and if you asks
if you ask a lot of um health care folks
that are that have studied statistics
for epidemiology they'll tell you that
well I'm never changing my title it's
epidemiologists you know I manage
disease conditions and populations and I
try to predict who is going to get
cancer or who is going to get over you
know who's going to be morbidly obese
going back to your comment earlier about
the definition of Nate data science Nate
Silver said that data science is
essentially a sexed-up term for
statistics so that's just another
another good example there so now in
terms of second example I'm going to go
back to Berlin now sober lane and
venture capital so what are we doing a
chakra right now um essentially what
we're doing is collecting you know it
still is kind of small data sets right
collecting data sets from startups or
private companies is what we call them
around growth so things like well your
key KPIs so cosplays your acquisition
burn race generates revenue growth
customer growth and then using that to
you not only connect them to venture
capitalists based on an index that way
that we calculated on the back end using
Python but also trying to predict
success as well and and actually look at
aggregate aggregate so looking at you
know companies on the Berlin level
looking at companies on on the European
level and then obviously trying to make
it draw on various insights from that so
if obviously in Berlin doing that it's a
little bit of a challenge a little
because I don't think anyone has
mentioned this here but um when you stop
sort of experimenting with the other
signs or you know with data and you want
to actually apply it in safe in the
financial sense there's definitely a lot
of regulation um a lot of resilience to
that because it's still developing so
that's the biggest thing that we're
finding here is that when you start
applying data to certain industries that
are super regulated um in an environment
that is not comfortable with
transparency you have a little bit of
pushback and so we've seen that here in
finance um but also here as well in
healthcare um so there wasn't there was
a study done recently that said that in
Europe there is a shortage of 50,000
jobs in data science so we also kind of
gives you a sense of um you know some of
the UM yeah some of the applications
that yeah I think there's not much that
hasn't and said on this topic now I
think go back to the original question
about industries where I think I kind of
see see a bit of a like three tiered
Parmenter the there the the the
companies where you can make data signs
and if you want predictive modeling a
core product that you sell like this is
what we're doing for example and I think
it's very nice place to be in because
you get to do a lot of interesting stuff
but there is a limit to how many like
categories there are right so you know
it's not surprised that
not a lot of you know you didn't name a
lot of them I think below that there is
a there's a level which it is much
broader we're like you know much more
data is just being produced over the
last decade or two that can now be
harnessed to create product features to
kind of improve and offering or give
like a new angle that wasn't previously
available and i think you know much like
Trent was saying thats everywhere more
or less and then on another layer below
that you kind of have what was probably
traditionally business intelligence
where you kind of can use data science
to achieve certain business goals that
not necessarily sort of like surface at
the level where and end user might see
it but it helps improve you know the the
kinds of offerings you provide or the
way you message something or your
revenue figures and all that and I think
that really goes that really goes into
all industries I don't think there is
can think of one that couldn't benefit
from that or won't be changed by that in
the future I think we have another
question from the audience I have a
question about the synergy between the
research and Industry so you know in the
research field people do sometime very
basic research and find some optimized
algorithm and and like that where at in
the industry people had a set of tools
is stabilized tools to use to analyze
the data something so how the industries
are active to look the recent research
output from the academia our research
labs so I guess who wants to take that
one go so I've actually been on both
sides of the fence here where I was a
student that was funded by industry and
also where I was the industrial partner
funding students and it works the in my
view the company should never ever rely
on the output of the student that's the
core sort of principle it but it it's
it's basically a bonus so basically if
the student manages to pull something
off then great so that's
kind of one thing and the other thing is
well defined well scoped projects I and
that's much more useful to industry you
know I think it's if you're a larger
company you can bro you know and this is
from the perspective of smaller
companies if you're a larger company
with thousands of employees sure maybe
you can you know employee pay for a PhD
student for you know five years it'll
probably cost you half a million euros
and go for it right and maybe you'll
have nothing coming out that's fine if
you want to have that label of that
university on your company website or
something great for smaller companies
though it's more you know well-defined
projects and so on so and we've actually
had benefit from that in the companies
that have been involved with where we
have these well-defined research
projects where a masters or a PhD
student works on it for three months six
months nine months they present the
results and we sometimes integrate that
this other ways to where you know we
provide the industry can provide tools
or free access to software that's very
helpful as well as universities are
often looking for industrial partners so
just you know attaching your name to
that you know that research proposal
that grant proposal can be very very
helpful and I've been in general the
companies I've been involved with we're
very open about that even if we don't
see any benefit if the professor wants
to use our company's label and to go for
it great i just say we're not going to
commit much time or resources from our
part welcome in some and then it'll
benefit you and maybe we'll get some
benefit but in general never ever too
late expect a whole lot at the end you
know anything that we get is gravy but
this is this is also beneficial from a
student angle right because then you say
i'm working with this company i'm
working with the supervisor this is how
I might get used it cetera et cetera so
just understanding the needs of both
sides yeah I like that yeah the good
question I definitely think that it
depends on the industry and the company
some companies are very open to research
and using resource to draw insights um
I'll say that I'll give you an example
in our case so right now we're having
conversations with some universities
around what we're doing um and I think
the biggest thing that at least for
industry is typically you're you know
when you're in this case and venture
capital you're trying to get information
so that you can make decisions not just
to collect the data
and so some of the things that we talked
about with that university is well we
don't want to just do research for doing
the purpose of research we need to
actually marry research with outcomes so
I think that's where you I guess
depending on the organization you have
this conversation in figure out what
what you want to do in terms of at least
in terms of what I'm seeing for certain
industries like health care and and
finance I mean I've seen situations
where pharmaceutical companies this is a
great example they have their R&D teams
and then they have the innovation teams
and a lot of times there's certainly a
lot of a lot of times a little separate
I'm and they try to draw insights from
that so I guess it really depends on the
organization what the funding is because
some people don't like to waste money or
they consider wasting that money um and
yeah I guess yeah that's my comment just
okay thank you you had the discussion
about what is data science I would have
a question what is industry you asked in
boxes and you stole me out of the boxes
most i take the machinery machine ball
unlock poem and the construction maybe
Germany worldwide and they have now the
problem to find new products new
business models new to new revenue
streams maybe if they think about
electronics or IT is standard what we
have we can deliver this missing link
one example could be germinated talk
about small politics into sniffing oil
but I mean this multi-industry of things
you measure something you have MEMS like
micro electromechanical systems are very
low very much degree of freedom you can
measure and control and so on but you
can put them now into the business level
and have new business rules could this
be a new kind of thing we can deliver
from this interdisciplinary approach we
have from this big data and also this
data scientist knowledge to help those
people not just revenue but to
understand better their business
to make them competitive in two or three
years because the machines are perfect
there's no triple OG problem to solve
okay they are not awesome yeah but this
is a percentage or sub person yeah pro
meter we are looking ok ok health care
is amassed data and fin take but could
you comment on this because I think this
is a very great shortage and not only
50,000 we could give some million people
better job if you support them with
intelligent algorithms incorporated in
machines maybe a service not running on
site yeah or like detectors in
high-energy physics we have the basic
data and only metadata but this need
knowledge you have to think and I think
this is what is shared here we are
thinkers and problem solvers so out of
the box means to have a new ideas for
new investors may be can you can comment
on this Thanks sure I'm I mean out say
that like the quickest way to comment on
that is when you talk about I guess data
science or research or insight and you
want to go and sell that to
organizations a lot of times you're
dealing with management and management
and you have to convince management and
some managers haven't been sold yet
right um if we think about what data
science is and when it even started I
mean I moved to Berlin two years ago um
in back in the US when I was where I was
doing what I was doing there we didn't
even have that term so it's still there
is definitely an educational process to
go with a lot of these managers to
figure out like okay so let's talk about
the issues in your organization and how
can we how can we use our you know our
talent to draw insights with that with
the to how much data do you have how are
you massaging our data right now how are
you join in size from that data and how
can I help you like benefit your
businesses so um that's it number one
number two is within the organizational
structure at least four large
organizations you have quite a lot of
like silos so you have the IT director
or the itv p
who might be already up to date with
data or trends or still in the old world
um or you um you have innovation
department or so there's various various
silos and you kinda and you kind of have
to either figure out how to work with a
champion with your organization to make
that happen or figure out how you can
get all of them to collide as you can
imagine a lot of these organizations
have meetings with 50 people in it for
example or ten people in it to make
decisions and so each one has to be
convinced about the value of that very
short comment we have familiar with this
we know this these are large
organizations these are sylosis are
monoliths these are Dino's hours but if
you go to German mittelstand you know
this they are very eager to be
competitive we call them hidden
champions yeah so they are the best
they're not known and not visible but
Tom few note humph it's in shriveling
they make a soldering or laser cutting
and things like this they want to deploy
something like app store for their
machines they don't know Google or Apple
play or of course they know this but
they say we need a store for apps for
our machines for refurbishment for
reconfiguration edges etc etc yeah but
they're not in this world so they come
from the business side they come inside
so they know their business and
management this is family owned this
isn't slightly different from the big
companies and I think they think very
forward and eager to have this or bosh
maybe same I think we can deliver this
missing link and address the people
budget or better go to people with
profit and loss and they have this
understanding don't come with data don't
come with a Python or IG no
domain-specific language and knowledge
and annotation I think we can help them
I mean sorry for if you come over that
so I think in the end it's all about the
business cases so you have to you have
to find with with expertise domain
knowledge in that specific area you have
to
to find the things which are really bad
for the customers and come with a
business case and then you can convince
and of course you need some champions
inside of the companies to convince the
others but usually you can come you
cannot come without the business case
then you are just out so this means you
have to understand the business of the
customers so that seems like a very good
opportunity for any consultancies there
in the german area and i'm going to have
to wrap this up because it's lunchtime
and i'm hungry i'm sorry but it was a
very interesting set of experiences
there about the branding and the
challenges and I completely agree about
the champions and organization there's a
lot of educational selling that needs to
be done then a lot of workshops I've run
in Luxembourg have been to business
leaders about what is data science why
should you care these sort of things in
the community there I I noticed a lot of
people throughout Europe are still
running these sort of things so that
means there's a tremendous opportunity
for growth so it's a very good time to
to join these or worlds so am ID like to
everyone to thank the panel and they
were great
and does anyone have any final words
because use all have lots to say I think
one of the main thing is that we should
be pushing for especially all of a
sudden know python already is a try to
encourage more people to learn the
language because i'm coming from
literature background and python made
sense for me when i looked at it it was
clean it was pretty but at the same time
it was close to english that i can
understand it and I feel that in Germany
it's almost expected that if you're a
programmer you have a CS degree you know
you have all these papers in your CV
saying you've done all these awesome
things and do we need to not only
educate people and programming but also
educate people that programming is a
tool it's like a hammer or wrench or
nail something that you can use to get a
final result and I think that's missing
in some people's perceptions of what we
do I mean a lot of us aren't CS
graduates we come from varied
backgrounds so it really means that
anyone who can solve a puzzle can learn
to program okay thank you very much
you